Netflix are that thing 30% of the people
watching this right now have open in
another tab is the world's most popular
streaming service with some 70 million
plus subscribers for anyone who's ever
been a little curious about that
benevolent red logo that contains so
many streaming options here are a few
little-known facts about Netflix the
mythical origin story you might have
heard the story about how Netflix
founder Reed Hastings got the idea for
the company after being slapped with a
$40 late fee from Blockbuster after
returning his rental of Apollo 13 past
it's due date that revenge narrative
might be nice and all but the real story
is a lot more complicated hastings
basically made the tale up as a buzzy
bee for crowds but the truth was that he
co-founded the site with the help of
mark randolph through a long and
complicated process that would have been
a lot less headline friendly as randolph
remembered they first got the idea for
mail and orders from amazon tested out
DVD durability by mailing one another a
CD and seeing if it could survive the
transit when it did they got busy
creating the catalog queue and no late
fee model and started counting up their
subscribers by by blockbuster when
netflix first began it was a mail order
service for movies and TV titles that
offered a convenience factor above the
local brick-and-mortar blockbusters
where you'd have to grapple with finding
it disc on its shelves and face hefty
late fees if you turned it into late but
netflix wasn't initially aiming to make
its central competitor obsolete
quite the opposite in 2000 the company
offered blockbuster the chance to buy it
out for 50 million dollars and get in on
the Digital streaming game during its
inception it might seem like a deal now
but at the time it was a Scoville
offense to the former powerhouse chain
when the offer was made Netflix was
actually hemorrhaging money which meant
that the valuation of 50 million dollars
was way more than the company was
actually worth also Netflix didn't just
want to be absorbed by blockbuster they
wanted to partner up to front the
company's entire online presence so
basically it was a situation where a
feisty up-and-comer company went to its
Goliath rival and demanded money and
power he has a suggestion have the money
by tomorrow and there won't be any
problem you can see why blockbuster
declined of course in retrospect it was
the first of many colossal mistakes that
would bring blockbuster down and earn
some serious schadenfreude from all the
mom-and-pop video shops that were
destroyed during its own rise but that's
another story altogether
adjusting the algorithm although Netflix
got its start in postal pictures it's
now been dwarfed by its own digital game
and while several competitors have since
popped up including Hulu and Amazon
Prime Netflix is still a mogul in the
marketplace thanks in large part to its
unique approach to algorithms while some
services might simply classify a movie
or show based on their MPAA ratings or
genres Netflix takes great links to
catalog the titles in its library with
more specific tags like what era the
movies take place in whether they were
critically acclaimed and if they belong
to a niche sub-genre is there any chance
you like monkeys in 2014 a curious data
Titian worked through the code of
Netflix and found the site has over
75,000 different micro genres that it
uses to categorize movies and shows
these genres are largely hidden from the
user and most people will rarely see
even a fraction of them while browsing
that's also kind of the point
they'll tuck away those pics about
werewolves on wheels in place of family
cartoons about unicorns if that seems to
be your thing and they can tell what
you're really into because tracking
devices one of the most valuable assets
at Netflix disposal right now is its
subscriber usage data along with
collecting key information like what you
watch when you watch it and for how long
Netflix also pinpoints when you pause
rewind or stop watching something in an
attempt to figure out why this part in
fact never play this again this data on
its own isn't all that useful but when
cross-reference with geographical
information the same data produced by
its millions of fellow subscribers it
can be used to produce comprehensive
charts detailing exactly what people
watch and what they give up on halfway
through Netflix guards these details
under lock and key but it does help them
figure out what belongs in the permanent
library collection and what can be
purged after a few months so remember
kids the next time you press pause you
may just be holding the fate of a
features future in your hands
original content thanks to its ad free
existence Netflix doesn't play the
scripted content game quite like the
television networks do the revenue
stream comes from subscribers so writers
of its original shows and movies have a
greater degree of flexibility when it
comes to length and narrative arcs
structures whereas a show episode on
cable might have to factor in commercial
breaks and chop up the storyline
accordingly Netflix shows run
uninterrupted and not only do show
runners have more creative control as a
result but
flic subscriber data helps them to know
in advance which series have the best
chances of succeeding for example with
house of cards Netflix had no qualms
about giving director David Fincher
approximately four million dollars per
episode because they have dated to prove
that users love the original British
series and since their shows don't
necessarily live and die by their
viewership ratings Netflix alone gets to
make the call whether to continue that
prestige series that's getting them on
the emmys map but might not draw every
eye in the nation all at once
piracy prevention in addition to
tracking which shows its customers watch
and how often they press pause Netflix
also has analysts track what stingy
people are torrenting on the web like
the data it collects from subscribers
piracy figures represent an invaluable
insight into viewing habits that Netflix
uses to adjust its own programming after
all if people are willing to risk
infecting the computer with a virus to
watch Game of Thrones it probably means
someone is willing to pay a few dollars
to watch a similar show from the comfort
of their toilet Netflix has even been
reported to use the geographical data of
pirates to adjust its pricing lowering
the cost of their service in areas with
high rates of piracy in an attempt to
lure viewers over to the SS Netflix it
might not be enough to bring ashore
every swashbuckler on the web a great
part does not require such intricacy but
it's certainly some solid reasoning
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]